Professor George paresi he's a renowned
theoretical physicist currently a
professor of quantum theory at the
University of Rome in 20121 he won the
Nobel Prize for his groundbreaking
contributions to the theory of complex
systems What secrets lie in the elegant
movement of a flock of Starlings what
can complex systems tell us about the
nature of life our universe and
ourselves welcome everybody to an
exciting episode of the into the
impossible podcast we're joined today by
an inspiring physicist a man who's made
many contributions to our understanding
of Nature and especially the
understanding of what are called complex
systems we're going to get into that but
the first thing we love to do on this
podcast Georgio is to talk about the
title of the book that you have written
it's called in a flight of
Starlings the wonders of complex systems
can you explain Georgio what does the
title mean and what is the cover art
what does it illustrate on the cover
picture the point is the following I've
been interested for a long time in the
flight of Starling I mean Starling are
very interesting birs and they are doing
the flight in a very huge group of of
thousand thousand especially in the
evening just uh just the moment where
when they have to go to sleep and the
point was that the Mage that these BS
are doing are really amazing fascinating
but no one knew
exactly how they could have communicate
to do this such this movement and the
think that was most fundamental no one
really knew which was the form of the
flock because when you see a frock B
you see the Mage that you have on your
retina but you don't see the three
dimensional shape and usually when in
order to see the three dimensional shape
you use two eyes but with two eyes you
can see the distance object which are
nearby so which was the solution the
solution was to put two I we decided to
do an experiment about that it took few
few years to do and people still working
on the problem and to see how really the
staring flight and the solution was to
put two eyes at the distance of 20 M of
course you cannot put really your eyes a
distance of 20 M but you can put Sun
camera as a distance of 20 M make
except uh make the
synchronized pictures
photograms of the staing between with
these two camera and having a
threedimensional
reconstruction this is not so easy but
at the head we succeeded to do so when I
decided we decided to write the book on
complex system and one of the chapter
was set dedicated to the bels after the
book was finished with we decided with
the edit of the order we discussed the
the chapters we discussed to put the
chapter on BS on Starling in the F and
also because is some sense the one that
is most fascinating most easy to be
understood and at the end we started to
discuss the title and we arrive to Z one
yeah it's a brilliant book it's very
short it's very readable and it's
endorsed by none other than our friend
Carlo relli who is coming back on the
the podcast for his 20th book I think it
must be on white holes and I take you
guys I don't know if you know this but
Carlo and I recorded the first ever
audio book by
Galileo so here is Galileo there's a
mini puppet of galileia he's holding his
telescope and it reminds me in your book
when you talk about devising not maybe a
new way to see things that uh that were
never seen before but a different
perspective and Galo said the following
when he was inducted into the L lych you
say lych Society lych yes of the links
the
link that's right he said a scientist
should measure what is measurable and
make measurable what is not yet so was
this discovery that you made with your
colleagues was this hiding in plain
sight was this something that could have
been discovered earlier or did it really
require the new technology not maybe
maybe of the telescope but but of the
camera technology could your discoveries
have been made 30 years ago 40 years ago
it's the things on Starling I think that
was just the first moment it could be
done the reason is the
following we needed to have a huge
number of photographer because was
really a movie
and in order to do this be before us you
have to do with estimated that we needed
in anyhow and they we use tens of
thousand of photograph now to to and now
this have to be used in somewhat in a
digital way because they have to be
analyzed by computer now the very idea
to have a something like an archive with
10 or th 10,000 maybe 100,000 photograph
and they look into them the digitize all
of them is something that
really a big big mess so I think that
that we started just at the moment we
the ca technology was good for using
these things because we had the S at
that moment there were a four megapixel
camera there was the Apper professional
one Canon that were able to shot eight
photogram per second
so that was just the one that went out
the price was
$5,000 we had to buy six of them or
eight of them so but it was not a real
problem of the price the point is that
the things really did not exist
digital camera of high precision and I
speed when I look at your history of
collaboration uh it's impossible for me
to not ask you about your advisor Nicola
kabo can you talk a little bit about him
as an advisor we and and maybe explain a
little bit for my audience what was he
known for what was his big contribution
to physics that probably warranted a
Nobel Prize in my opinion but uh what
did what was nicoa like as an adviser
and what did he do for physics ni it was
a wonderful advisor was a wonderful
advisor because
was very friendly with a student and the
things that he really did he was
transmitting enthusiasm for the science
was Mak an interest in doing science in
the good way in the right way and
without caring too much of the publicity
of result but the real point was to
understand the deeply what one have to
do and also the other things that I
remember very well him that when we're
discussing some possible things to be to
study together the point was that one
should try to pick something which is
amusing I think that it's amusing for
the scientist and I think that this is
important because if you start some
project which is very boring at the
middle you are going to stop it you're
are not going to finish it so to some
kind of amusing I mean Amusement which
is the same kind of amusement that may
have people when they solve P but it's
important to Trav now Nia had been a
really great scientist in the 60s and
the 70s he made a lot of discoveries
about the behavior in which what people
call radio activity I means people
nowadays call weekend interactions I
mean are
the some forces which is not strong as a
strong fores and the think that he
really understood the way that this
particle
interacts will say at the present moment
how PS do interact in the week in the
week and introduces what people called
after him theab angle and the angle at
the basis of present theories of we
interaction he could add the Nobel Prize
in 2008 I believe but uh things happened
that the the Noel committee decided to
not go give to him doing some argument
which things were factually wrong but
sometimes also the no committee makes
some mistakes when I think of him as an
adviser and a contributor it didn't seem
like he was bitter about not winning I
mean it seemed like he was committed to
his students and to the science with
enthusiasm so is that a trait that you
mimic um with your students did you
learn as an advisor to to many students
and formally and informally as well to
many millions of people probably what
lessons in terms of Education or being a
mentor did you learn from him yes I mean
I I think that I'm trying to transmit
enthusiasm for Science and enthusiasm
for science is quite important to do and
of
course you have to do in the right way I
means you have to sit down near your
student to understand what they're doing
help them to do and
also you have to encourage them I mean
if they you if they're able to solve
things in some way which is not the best
way I think that you should let them go
on and not explain that could be done in
a much simpler way because otherwise
they take you take out from them the The
Joy or having discovered something and
the think that I've done I've done
things in well because
there there was a nature the magazine n
made a a price for
mentoring and this was I think in 2015
there were the price of mentoring in
Italy and I think I was one of the three
guys that won the price for best
mentoring in Italy so and this
was based also on the reports of my
student who wrot a very enthusiastic
report well certainly so I think it's
Latin and you'll correct me if I'm wrong
but the word educate in Latin is EduCare
and it means not to pour into but to to
bring out of and so I I think you've
brought out a lot in your students and
your colleagues and it seems to me
you're you have a uh quite a good deal
of of humility uh as well as sort of the
confidence to pursue these incredible
questions and when I was reading the
book I started to wonder about these
murmurations so a murmuration is a
collective um noun for starlings when
they flock together and almost as if
they become a different entity like a
different organism can you uh describe
what uh what they're actually doing why
do they do this is it is it for to scare
off Predators is it to uh migrate is it
to attract mates what what is the
evolutionary purpose of a murmuration
well that was well understood the
biologist much before we entering the
game the things is clear these
SPS do not like cold weather therefore
in in summer time there stays in north
of North Europe I mean and during the
winter they are more or less in November
to R and they spend the winter up to the
to march in that period things they have
to find a place with which are relative
warm because they do not have enough
many things to eat they have some fat
but the amount of fat that they able to
burn is not so high so the point to find
a place which is good which is warm that
you must have some trees which have
leaves and there should be not too many
cats that go on on the trees because
that will be better for other reason so
so what happens is that when they come
they go in the countryside during the
day so they they commuting they Comm
they go in the countryside in the day
and they come in the evening to sleep
inside the city but anyhow they commute
and when they come back they have to
find out a good place some of them will
find out the good place or the same may
be the same the previous day so they
start to make some kind of ation M on
the top of the place and the other bir
that arrives they see this kind of
mation and after they becoming bigger
bigger and when it's the moment to go to
sleep which is usually half an hour
after the dawn they go to sleep and this
mation can be seen from a very large
distance I remember that I was able to
see on the sky room and more or less at
10 kilom of distance so they are
something that you can easily see in the
sky because you don't see usually the
sky objects that moves make change and
so on yeah they're quite uh they're
quite mesmerizing are they um describing
them with the tools of condens matter
physics do they exhibit phase
transitions do they exhibit you know
first order or free
are there things that we can connect to
our you know introductory thermodynamics
classes that a student can understand
about their behavior or is it really
unique to these birds and the fact that
they're birds are there commonalities
critical points phase transitions how do
they behave in a physics from a
physicist perspective well from the
point of view of physic perspective one
have to take care that these BS are out
equilibrium because usually when they
see is doing the standard textbook for
thermodynamics on one is looking through
all system which are equilibrium and now
I what people call teral equilibrium and
now these BS are not a teral equilibrium
but
however thody I mean thermodynamics the
physics of these last years had done a
lot of progress to discuss a system
which are not at what people call ter
equilibrium and
therefore one can you describing this
this B by physical law one can write
something like reation motion Collective
regation motion one can speak of a
normalization group first transition and
the things that happens that the way
that the this BS move is essential that
they stay essentially at the critical
point the reason for which they choose
the type of parameter with they using in
doing in flight to say near the critical
point is that when you are near a
critical point the face transition the
speed is going to the speed of speed of
information inside the system is going
to move very very fast indeed what this
what happens in this case because in
half a second all the flops have decize
to turn in One Direction Another
direction we know that when they turn
there a few bir they start to turn other
which is typically in the center of the
flock other bir are fing but the signal
that someone is starting to move
propagate very very fast my thumb is
very busy right now holding up good old
Albert but if yours is free please go
ahead and hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm and when I thought
about the murmurations it cross my mind
that maybe human beings can exhibit
these same kinds of behaviors but not
know about it um are there phenomena
maybe not physical phenomena because we
you know except when we go to a a
football game uh we don't really be
behave as huge flocks but are there sort
of social behaviors maybe obsessions or
or or so forth that human beings also
can act as murmurations or am I wrong
the point the point about the
oration it's that each bird is going to
imitate the other the birds nearby
because he has to avoid C and so on and
therefore there is many many things in
in a society where people try to imitate
other human being and try to imitate
other human being for example you can
think of fashion but also the other
there's one particular case case that we
have studied and is the distribution of
baby names in the United States now you
see that you have in certain moment you
have a certain fashion for example in
the 60s genifer was a very common name
nowadays I don't know what may be a very
common name maybe sa Bella or something
like that and now what you you can if
you look to the distribution names
United States you see there are some
states which have nearly the same
distribution name of other states and
other states that had different things
and now what we did we analyze
numerically this distribution names
because we have the recording of the
names that were given to baby in the
last century and something and for
example the things that discovered that
for example in in the one century ago
the great division was the norn count
and the southern one that were
quite different way and now what happens
essentially after the thing change in
the 70s and now the east coast and the
West Coast go very well together and the
center part United States goes in in
another Direction something like I would
say that you the
Democratic the Democratic State use
different names and the Republican one
roughly speaking and now this is clearly
that this in effect is clearly an effect
that people here probably different
television
channel read the different newspaper
read the read a different uh things have
a different friends for in the United
States and also we that is something
that we published and also we started to
study if one can understand this type of
waves which are the state which they F
start and we found but we had not
finished our study that there are some
state which start two three years before
the other some kind some kind of fashion
and after the other State systematic
imitate so this is something that that
can be done in many many
different subject the only point is to
have the data because if we would have
the data of book sold in each state of
the United States by Amazon one could do
this kind of study but I feel that we it
would be very hard to have from Amazon
this kind of data yes yeah I agree
that's fascinating let's turn towards
now the research that you did kind of
buried the lead as they say I I didn't
mention that you won the Nobel Prize uh
normally I do that in the intro but I
I'll I'll clean that up when I actually
edit the video but I want you to now
drop in and start talking about your
work on spin glasses they're so
fascinating and uh and the the Curiosity
I think my audience would have is what
inspired you to do that and invent this
concept and collaborate to make this
occur and then possibly talk about some
technological implications of them so
let's start with what is glass first of
all what is glass and why how does it
have an applicability to spin I mean if
you have you know my glass starts to
spin I've got problems over here so tell
me what is glass first of all and then
what is a spin glass because I think the
public understanding won't be as clear
until you explain it rather than me
let's let's say to the following
supposed that to take water you cool
water and it become ice and we know that
this happens a very precise temperature
32 fahit and so say what happens here in
that case a well defined transition for
something that you call Liquid to
something that you call solid now
suppose that you look to the W wa of a
candle I mean when you
see when you see that it goes down you
see that is liquid and after going out
from the fire it become more and
more solid but it's not really solid
it's something that you can push your
finger in and the formate and becoming
cooler and cooler become more and more
rigid now in this case Cas you have you
don't have a real face transition you
have a situation in which you have a
liquid that a certain moment becomes
so so rigid that you cannot really push
it and you have many many other type of
liquid of this type like for think of
hor hor is liquid but you you usually
don't do but if you put in a freak
become really solid so you have a lot of
things and re glasses the window glass
belong to this category and in V you can
see what how people work with
glasses when they are very hot now spin
glasses is some kind of material which
have some glass property they be some
respect as glasses but they are done
with pins but if you ask me why I was
interested I I became interested at the
moment which I did not know anything
about spin glass the only thing that I
know that there was a mathematically
difficult problem in the sense that
somebody had tried to give a Sol
solution but the solution was factur
wrong was
inconsistent and now so I started to
study how to solve the mathematical
problem and at the end of one here I
found the solution of finding of um
Computing the quantities were needed to
computed and for all that video I was
not at all interested to what P glass
were to which was the
possible experimental
experimental realization I mean all the
if you want to the all physics connected
to sping glass was not interested to me
it was just a problem
that I want to solve because also
because maybe I want to show that I'm am
good in solving problems but not
particularly interested to it and that
moment I left the problem and after a
few years three four year we started by
speaking with people to understand
better the meaning of the solution we
started to have a new interest in the
problem we started to look in better and
realized that the problem was connected
that to to complex system but it was a
discovery that was done by analyzing f a
problem a few years after that was that
was done and that was due also to the
fact that other people were looking to
the problem and therefore I also I found
there was interesting things to be
understood and I started to look again
and after looking again in details one
started that wasn't connected to complex
system and a spin spin glass itself is
embedding magnetic or metallic particles
in inside of a of a glass is I
understand it are there any
technological applications uh resistors
you know transistors quantum computers
are there any technological spin-offs
from these magical devices no I as far
as I know spring glass have no no one
has found a real application of spring
glass someone was thinking maybe to have
application as memory but was too
complex to be done no what was had a lot
of Technologic spin off was a theory
that was behind the spin glasses because
the theory that was behind the F glass
was not not so different from the theory
that offield wrote down for the for the
first modern type of neural network and
the sping glass and the theory of sping
glasses was fundamental in the work that
was done by other people by the
israelian group L by armit to have a
deep understanding of the off model of
newal network but and this made a strong
push toward understand the neural
network many people started to study
analytically neural network because
using the theory modification the theory
know the type for example people were
able to compute using this kind of
theory which was the maximum amount of
things that a off network will be able
to memorize and in the and in in this
kind of way wave of interest for new
network in the '90s people started to to
propose what the Deep
Network which now are the Deep networks
the Deep new network are now at the
basis of modern artificial intelligence
let's summarize that the interest in Sp
class in the 80s and the also a deep
influence of the beginning neural
network and this newer Network are now
artificial intelligen of these days so
my first book uh is called losing the
Nobel Prize and it's about uh the story
of how I came to invent an experiment
that was looking for Cosmic inflation
and trying to understand the origin of
the Big Bang via the imprint on the
cosmic microwave background radiation
and how if we had been proven correct
then our if the experiment had been
confirmed then one somebody would have
won the Nobel Prize maybe not me but
everybody agreed that this was the case
and in fact we got a lot of attention
and then spoiler alert we did not win
the Nobel Prize and that's the name of
the title but um a lot of people
criticized me and they said well you
can't lose the nobell prize because you
don't really have it until you lose it
and I said that doesn't make any sense
you can't lose a football game because
you didn't win the football game um but
it actually occurs to me that you did
lose a Nobel Prize in certain sense uh
back in and you describ this in the book
uh to Kenneth Wilson can you talk a
little bit about what Kenneth Wilson did
what you almost did as well can you talk
about your actual losing the Nobel Prize
before you actually won it there were
two moments when I was very very young I
was
25 that
I lose in some sense at the no price the
first one one was that I was interested
to the same problem that Ken Wilson was
interested to understand the
renormalization to not renormalization
group because rization group was IDE
wison to understand second the face
transition but in this case there was no
match because Ken had had so many ideas
and they was working on the problem in
the last 10 years and so I clear that I
could not really match him start in in
one or two years time so he had when
just at the moment where I arriv to
start to think about the problem he came
out with a solution so this was really
no match the things on which we were
quite near was the B point point of view
of syntic Freedom a syntic freedom which
is was a wonderful idea that got the
Nobel Prize by R wi poit in
2002 or 2004 I never remember yeah 2004
yeah Frank Frank has been on the he's
been a guest on the podcast
well and Po got the Noel price in 2004
for ctive freedom but at that moment I
was
interested to this type of problems and
I knew that the same computation of Po
gross we was done by to that was left
unpublished but to and not try to apply
this type of computation to physic to
real physics which was opposite of gross
where real check they discussed the
quantum prodynamics so the things I me
remember that I discuss I I was in s
with to and we start to discuss how can
one construct a model of physics in
order to use this discover now we have
only discussed half an hour because I
was interested mainly to add a problem
in connector transition but also was
interested quanti gravity and just the
right solution that was model that was
proposed by G man two years ago that I
knew very well I did I did not like the
model in reality but I knew the model
very well it came not to my mind the
idea of applying to that model now is if
if some if I get a idea or someone would
be present in the discussion and would
just say but what about the man model is
clearly that all the we could write a
very similar paper to those people got
the Nobel price in the in two days
because all the comput were done and was
easy for me to spell all possible
application but the idea did not came to
our mind not I was the expert on
physical application to was more
interested to P Theory so the photo was
mine certain not
G but anyhow we we get something that in
this case I was quite near a few ctim
away and the things escaped
also maybe it could be a mess because as
far as probably also the other people in
in the United States would arrive the
same moment would have five people with
s Discovery and which will make Kosar
for the Noel priz committee but I really
do not know what would happen well my
second book uh uh thankfully is is not
as obsessed with the Nobel Prize uh
being lost but it's about how to win one
potentially so this is my second book
it's called think like a Nobel Prize
winner and it's all about how you can
collaborate and work with people uh to
make the world more understandable so I
want to ask you about collabor ation and
how you view collaboration is it
possible for scientists to work in
isolation and and um not be involved
with say experimental results if you're
a theoretical physicist or if you're a
theor experimental physicist to not
understand the theory is it possible to
do things by yourself nowadays or is it
only possible with the help of
collaborators well I think that is
really very very difficult to do things
by to have one man work of course
sometimes we do have but this is just an
isolated isolated the spot I would say
because after in order to show the
importance of this isolated work you
need the work of many other people so
this type of collaboration is very
important I mean c I am very fun of
collaborating with people when I I I was
70 years old people had just done a
poster with all the names of people have
collaborated with and there were
317 people if two years ago one year ago
maybe people did an update version of
the poster with
360 so I am pretty sure that I'm suppos
to go more than 400 of different
collaborators sometimes our
collaborators are only one work
sometimes our collaborator which I
written 50 work together but I think
that collaboration is very important in
these days also because and what is said
important to exchange your ideas with
people because sometimes you have a same
idea but you there very often the idea
that people add Half Baked ideas and in
order to transform really final things
you have to explain to other people
discuss with them and so at least from
my point of of course there may be other
people that works in a different way I
understand I understand thanks many
discussion at least in the first paper
relativity with Bess and other friends
and so on the influence of
grman was very important because the
general for the gener relativity because
for gener
relativity it was was needed a
mathematics that iand did not know very
few people knew at that time Grossman I
really explained to him on the other
hand Ian won the Noel price for the
photoelectric effect was really
something that we he did by himself
first understand yes I think you're
right and what was so fascinating about
this book or many many fascinating
aspects of in a flight of Starlings by
today's guest Noel Laurette Giorgio
Parisi is that you kind of go through a
checklist of what it's like to have an
idea and it's in a chapter called how
ideas are born and I wonder if you could
comment on it you talk about these four
steps and we'll we'll put them on the
screen there's a first preparatory step
where the problem is studied existing
literature read and and first
unsuccessful attempts are made it's a
period that can last between a week and
a month because it ends when no progress
occurs then there's a period of
incubation step two in which the problem
is abandoned at least consciously three
the incubation ends suddenly with a
moment of Illumination which often
occurs unrelated in an unrelated
situation and then four after the
illumination provides uh the general way
to tackle the problem the solution must
be formulated can you talk about your
process your work process do you do you
follow this rigorously or s do you have
ideas that can be made to fruition
relatively quickly or do you really have
to wait for these moments of inspiration
followed by maybe a phow period when
you're waiting nothing much is happening
and you abandon it how does that
interplay work especially when you have
collaborators it's hard enough to have
one idea of your own but you have a
collaborator how do you get him or her
to abandon it and work on it Etc so can
you talk about your idea generation
process how our ideas born well the
point is the following that it's not
that I'm really following this program I
mean it's not something that I do
programmatically just thinking on a few
case in which I have some particular
good ideas and they also looking to
something that written the literature
because other people describe the way
that the go the frame case in which they
they do they tells I mean usually
scientist do not tells people how to
theya they only present the final result
but not the way they get there are
people that
discuss case of or there something that
is seen in the book of David after that
he wrot my one so many people describe
the way that they geta and some this is
something that is quite Comm of course
the the fact that you need the some
months is something that especially for
very important difficult ideas but uh
but in certain case also for simple or
for much as simple things is something
that you need to you work in a similar
way the only things that the time scales
much shorter for example I remember
sometimes at sat the morning to to look
to new program I realize this is a back
that does not work the problem go days
wrong and I spend the whole morning try
to understand what is wrong and I am not
able to find but but after that I start
to driving for going to home at
lunchtime doing driving I understand
what is wrong I go home and I check that
that was exactly the same thing so the
fact that sometimes looking back I mean
looking for a little fire away is
something that helps of course this when
you have a
collaborator the things are somewhat
easier if you are at this stage with
collaborator because you start to tell
your collaborator your ideas
at the first time they do not understand
but which are ideas so you have to be
formulated to formulate in a clear way
that are understandable by them I
remember
that for my six years one student of
mine gave me APR
Cactus I mean and small Cactus on
and it's saying this is the way that
come out
of today's episode centers on the math
behind complex systems so many people
are passionate about science but then
find themselves intimidated and
disengaged at the slightest hint of math
and this might discourage them from
their own shot at a Nobel Prize however
math becomes infinitely more intriguing
when intertwined with mathematical
Notions animations and brilliantly
planned lesson plans and that's why I
love brilliant it's a dynamic and
engaging platform for learning
mathematics data science and computer
science interactively I use it both on
the website and on the fabulous
brilliant app where you'll find a
treasure Trove of foundational Advanced
topics like group Theory artificial
intelligence networks and the course I'm
getting involved with data analysis it's
here to help people fall in love with
math and unlock new opportunities
regardless of your proficiency brilliant
tailor content to align with your
learning needs your pace so you can
progress at your own rate currently I'm
going through the lessons on the app for
their quantitative Financial modeling
course it's fantastic and opens up a new
set of recal in my brain a side of
mathematical analysis I've never even
encountered before it's a way of
gamifying and making the learning
process fun you start the lesson and
you're immediately drawn in with
brilliant fantastic animations and
customize pedagogical framework it's the
future of Education to try everything
brilliant has to offer for a full 30
days visit brilliant.com drbryan keing
or click the link below the first 200 of
you will get 20% off brilliant's annual
premium subscription well I have to ask
you about something controversial in
your field of condensed matter physics
although you've done so many things from
high energy particle physics to uh to
studying starlings but recently there
was a claim of the very first room
temperature ambient pressure uh high
temperature superconductor what did you
make of the the excitement and what do
you think is going to happen with high
temperature superc conductivity do you
think we'll have one you know in in the
next few decades or do you think it's
almost impossible to imagine well first
all home temperature super conductor
will be very useful first also doing
toys for children and also because there
will be lot
of a gadget which will consume much less
electricity so set will be very very
useful and I feel
that I mean I do not see any particular
reasons for which we should not have
high temperature superconductors of
course it's c that that this is very
difficult also because we really do not
fully understand why the actual super
doctors that reason that they are super
conductor at the
liquid oxygen liquid air temperature we
super the reason for which there super
conductor there are some recent paper
they claim they do understand but I
think that the the space amount of
different material that we can be
constructed is so huge that especially
the moment in which when we have a good
theory of high temperatur super
conductors I do not see any reason for
which we could not have a room
temperature super conductivity of course
may be wrong but I am quite confident
that we can arrive to hit I want to just
um ask about your work that you've been
leading to really bring scientific uh
funding in European governments uh to
the to the high level one of the topics
in the book is how much uh value that
science provides to a thriving uh
society and you talk about in the book
this famous uh joke by Nobel Prize
winner Richard feinan who said that uh
you know science is like sex sometimes
it produces useful results but that's
not why we do it can you talk about your
movement that you've been heading called
and I'm going to butcher this
salvano Italian I hope I didn't butcher
that can you talk about that what drove
you start this for society the point was
the following the in Italy the research
is not enough uh funded I mean the total
amount of money that Italy spending on
Research private and state to all
together is a little more than 1% of the
total gross uh income and total gr
product
and and this is something that opposite
to other countries like Germany we stay
nearly 2% France is already half% more
than Italy Korea is 4% so one and
something is really very bad for Italy
and this is really problem because with
this amount of spending many brilliant
Italian go abroad they do not remain in
Italy because there's not enough money
to do reasonable SE they go in other
countries and this is something that
makes Italy much poor so what I've been
started to push in the last 10 years in
last 15 years let's say and more maybe
20 more money for res this is something
which is many italian government did not
get more money the reason is that
although resarch is useful for
increasing the national gross product in
the long run it does not it's not in the
in the time interval between one
election and the other elections so they
are not really interested in doing that
so it's something that is very bad for
Italy and we for example the
M let say Italian rech was a moment in
which we start on a petition on
change.org
and we got 200,000 sen asking to get
more money to Italian rearch and this
took a certain amount of time to
organizing to get this number
signature but this I think was helpful
because it showed to the
politicians that research was was
important at that time I think that this
did not have any song effect on the
total amount of money that politicians
were to go on the only difference that
made that before people or the
politicians were not speaking about
research after the moment they were say
that we give a research a lot of money
but without increases amount of money so
so they understood that it was important
to say that they give money to the secep
very good and then the last thing um
that I wanted to bring up before I ask
my final question which is kind of a
philosophical question uh has to do with
a quote that you have in the beginning
of the book which uh was really it
inspired me to write a tweet which is
you know online I I said that um why do
we need to have science communicators
people whose job it is professionally to
communicate science we don't have that
with movie stars we don't have that with
football players so why is it that
science needs someone to make science
more popular and I got a lot of hatred
online you know people said oh that's
stupid you know movie stars do get paid
to go out and do it and I said well yeah
that's proving my point but scientists
should be communicating more to the
public is my My Philosophy and it's not
a surprise that we don't get much
funding because a lot of times we do
things to say that we can't really
explain it to you as a lay person
because you're not smart enough or we
say that it's too hard for us as
scientists to learn how to communicate
properly and I I say that's nonsense
it's it's hard to learn the
renormalization group uh so stopping
saying something is hard is not an
excuse so you said in the be at the end
of the preface you say the following I
wanted to start to emphasize how
difficult it is to understand the many
phenomena that we observe almost daily
and convey that complexity is not about
what happens in Laboratories it is what
happens all around us our job as
scientists is to to illuminate for
everyone the truths we discover can you
say if you agree with this I believe
scientists have a moral obligation to
communicate what they do in terms that
people that fund us can understand do
you agree with that or do you disagree
and if so how no I fully agree with that
and I I think the scient have to
understand that if they do not
communicate with people what they are
doing the funds will stop
eventually so I think not it is certain
moreal obligation but also a long long
period need to communicate with people
because science in these days it cost to
lot of money and we can think of some
kind of maybe not very efficient work in
which Technologies go on without science
and this is something that it may be
difficult but may be possible and or you
may have a situation which both techn
technology and science escape from small
countries like Italy this is also
another possibility so I think that
extremely important is a moral I agree
fully agree it's a moral obligation and
also convenience for them to communicate
it's not EAS I mean one have to study
because also communication with people
should be done also in a fast way
because you have to go to get the
attention of people and therefore it's
not easy to get the attention of people
and also because scientist you normally
are custom to use written words and uh
to and that this is not the way and and
and also to speak with people that are
interested like not the scientist now
the real problem for scientist to
communicate it to get the attention
other people and the moment they start
to communicate and that the things that
make things different because other
people or get immediate away just look
into them in the face you're interested
what they're doing but not scientist
Georgia that was beautiful um I really
appreciate your time and there's one
last question before I'll let you
return to have a a
bon and that's the uh that's the
question I like to ask my guests and ask
them to give them themselves advice when
they were 20 years old or 25 years old
and it's based on the name of this
podcast so this podcast is based on Sir
Arthur C Clark's Third Law which states
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture a little
way past them into the impossible so I
want to ask you a question Georgio for
your former self at age 25 what advice
would you give him to have the courage
to do as you've done to go into the
impossible what piece of advice if you
have 30 seconds with 25-year-old Georgio
what do you say to him this question was
already asked to me and after some
thought I says that I will not give any
advice because I've been very luly in in
the choice of things to study in my
trajectory and to hear some say I mean I
think that a lot of luck and I think
that any disturbance of theory will be
it would be very like to have a quite
negative effect well that's very smart
because here we have the Simpsons a very
famous cartoon where Homer Simpson goes
back in time and he he steps on a bug
and he goes stupid bug you go squish now
and then like Fast Forward 60 million
years later and uh human is a servant of
all these bugs so uh so Georgio I I want
to thank you so much for this wonderful
book um for the inspiration to millions
of people around the world you you made
uh so many people happy uh when you won
the Nobel Prize but really for the work
that you've done and this fabulous book
and I hope we can meet someday in in
person and have a cappuccino together
you are welcome if you come to Rome
capino here thank you m